[Music]
[Music]
the music and theater arts they inspire
all of MIT with new ideas new
experiences and just make some better
people and like better scientists better
engineers just better communicators
what's really exciting about MIT is it
has this unique opportunity for people
like me who are passionate about so many
different types of things where I don't
have to be a music major to participate
in high level music once we start with
her so like I completely forget that I
have a pset due tomorrow or that I have
an exam in three days it's just an
experience that completely takes you
away and I think that's what makes it so
enjoyable
[Music]
they sound amazing and it kind of made
me forget that they are not majoring in
their necessarily music so that's pretty
amazing the the high level that they
have here they're working very hard in
school to take time for music is not
easy for many of them and yet they bring
their best game to it and that makes it
a pleasure to work on things 94 wins who
have these sixteenth note figures there
should not be articulate through Arts at
MIT I've been able to interact with
literally my heroes musically Jam
cheetah raphy Chick Corea Anat Cohen
Miguel Zenon Don Byron these students
are so interested in life and trying so
hard to figure out what they can do and
discovering skills it's great to be part
of that it gives me energy every year
there are concerts here that I would
never have imagined being able to be a
part of the Jago culinary experience
going to Puerto Rico with Miguel the
clarinet summit
[Music]
so this is typical Fred I was just
walking down the infinite corridor one
day and I just happened to run into him
and he says oh hey Iran I have this idea
that and what are you doing on on May
11th and nice and I look at my calendar
and I said yeah I think I'm free it's
like great because we're gonna do this
clarinet summit it's gonna be amazing
I hope you can play it's like okay
sounds good thanks this whole thing came
to me in a dream and I can't believe it
actually happened it hasn't happened yet
but we've gotten this far so this is
very very cool
[Music]
there's been more and more of a
commitment throughout MIT to support
artistic endeavors even the wildest and
most ambitious ones and there's been
people like Fred who are willing to be
ambitious to come up with it wild an
amazing idea that then comes to life
[Music]
Freddie's mi t--'s energizer bunny he
worked harder than all of us Fred if
you're watching this go to bed seriously
he's he needs to
he's just leave mark okay good I have a
rehearsal pedagogy that I'm gonna
suggest for you and then I'll gonna
leave and then I'm gonna come back
Freddie really is a force to be reckoned
with he doesn't stop he keeps going and
his brain is always active and he's got
so many ideas and he's just brilliant
and he he loves people and he loves
music and he's a great collaborator too
I think I maybe went too far the other
way so I kind of have to bring it back
but it's better than the ink that's all
I can say
the man has Drive and he is so
incredible to watch and work with and
the passion he exudes is amazing is
there time could we like have one hour
on Friday is that do you do halftime see
if you can figure it out if you can't
not we don't not need a whole hour but I
think if we could run the piece a
thousand times Friday that would be good
he's respectful of the past but I think
he's got a vision for the future for
himself and for this the program and I
think he works tirelessly towards those
visions the students who have had the
chance to work with Fred in fje and in
MIT we are working with the musical
presence that's as powerful as her voice
it's profound I know it was for me and
still is for me and I think it will be
for all these students regardless of the
past that take whether it's in music or
not we hired Fred from his previous job
which was as a high school wind leader
we thought he was just the most
top-flight candidate we could have
imagined
he's been willing to take chances on
things that seem crazy at the outset I
mean getting Jacob to come for a week I
was like Fred you're not going to get
that to happen and now he's done it
twice
[Music]
just watching him conduct on stage you
think wow I want to have that level of
appreciation for music for it's such a
breadth of music to need so many
interesting things and he loves all of
it dearly
he's definitely someone who's very
humanitarian oriented and like really
wants to make a social impact and like
bring the community together
[Music]
Fred's guests have been a diverse crowd
and his idea of where he would like to
be involved has really pushed in the
direction of understanding other
cultures that are marginalized
when a hurricane first hit he helped
organize a fundraiser with MIT one
ensemble and the different groups he
does to send supplies to Puerto Rico the
whale song was one of Fred's wacky ideas
so the idea is that maybe this baby
whale or mother and baby are caught in
the net and just horribleness and then
this is sort of a requiem for them
[Music]
when Fred first introduced the idea of
playing with well sounds I was kind of
confused and when we performed it in
front of the audience you can kind of
tell that they were feeling what we were
trying to convey
[Music]
Fred's a good trucker I mean I now
played with him a lot the kids in the
van get a big kick out of the times when
he plays because they don't get to
actually hear him breathing
[Music]
he knows how to lift musicians and make
them wanna shine
he just has such a warm inspiring
character and so he knows how to make
people relax and he knows how to push
people for them to do their best
I'd like you to a Moute more I'd like
you to for lack of a better phrase to
kind of sell it musically more by
exaggerating the emotional moments via
dynamics and your soul I started out as
one of his mentor's when he was 14 years
old I was a big deal to him and as I
told the MIT Wind Ensemble the other
night when I rehearse with him at this
point he's one of my mentors he's a big
deal to me Fred single-handedly got me
through undergrad either indirectly or
directly by just encouraging me to make
music every time I talk to him I get so
much joy because he genuinely cares
about his students and he really works
hard to make sure that we're also just
doing well as human beings outside of
music
fred is also very mindful of challenges
that other people are dealing with he
would check in on me all the time and
say how can I help what can I do and
honestly it like having his support when
I was going through a lot was incredible
and I know I'm not the only student
who's had that experience with Fred so
I've had lots of teachers over the years
I've worked with lots of different
people and I do have to say that Fred
Harris is perhaps the most inspirational
person I've ever worked with a great
human being a great family man a great
colleague to all of us in the music
education community and a compassionate
and caring teacher for now thousands and
thousands of students he's very like
genuine about what he's expressing I
think fred is a genius sensitive but
also extremely smart and witty unique
thing about a Fred rehearsal is how much
time they spend actually playing the
music and how little time he expends
just a great mentor
[Applause]
[Music]
how was that water phone I heard it
pretty cool right
yeah I'll double-check but I think so
thank you for checking good night
you
[Music]